La réponse de la police face à une communauté en deuil était la force
pour imposer la peur :
la peur de la police militarisée,
de la prison,
des amendes.
Les médias ont voulu nous faire avoir peur des autres
par leur narration de l'histoire.
Toutes ces choses ont marché dans le passé.
Comme je l'ai dit, cette fois-ci, c'était différent.
La mort de Michael Brown et le traitement ultérieur de la communauté
ont mené à une série de manifestations aux alentours de Ferguson et St. Louis.
Quand je suis allé à ces manifestations, le quatrième ou cinquième jour,
ce n'était pas par courage ;
c'était par culpabilité.
Je suis noir.
Je ne sais pas si vous l'avez vu.
(Rires)
Mais je ne pouvais pas rester à St. Louis, à quelques minutes de Ferguson,
et ne pas aller voir.
Alors j'y suis allé.
Quand je suis arrivé,
j'ai découvert quelque chose de surprenant.
J'y ai découvert beaucoup de colère.
Mais encore plus d'amour.
Des gens avec de l'amour-propre.
De l'amour pour leur communauté.
Et c'était beau --
jusqu'à ce que la police arrive.
Alors, une nouvelle émotion a été introduite dans la conversation :
la peur.
Je ne vais pas mentir,
quand j'ai vu ces véhicules blindés,
tous ces attirails,
toutes ces armes
et tous ces policiers,
j'étais terrifié --
personnellement.
Quand j'ai regardé la foule,
j'ai vu que beaucoup ressentaient la même chose.
Mais j'ai vu des gens avec autre chose en eux.
C'était du courage.
Ces gens ont crié,
ils ont hurlé
et ils n'allaient pas reculer face à la police.
Cela était dépassé.
J'ai pu sentir quelque chose changer en moi,
alors j'ai crié et hurlé
et j'ai remarqué que tout le monde autour de moi en faisait de même.
Rien n'est comparable à ce sentiment.
J'ai décidé que je voulais faire plus.
Je suis rentré, je me suis dit que j'étais un artiste, je créais.
Alors j'ai créé des choses spécifiques à la manifestation,
des armes dans une guerre spirituelle,
donnant une voix aux gens
et qui les fortifieraient pour la suite du chemin.
J'ai réalisé un projet où j'ai pris ces photos des mains des manifestants,
les ai mises sur les bâtiments barricadés
et les magasins communautaires.
Mon objectif était d'alerter l'opinion publique et remonter le moral.
Je crois que, durant un instant,
j'ai réussi.
Puis j'ai voulu mettre en avant l'histoire de ces gens
qui étaient courageux dans l'instant.
Moi et mon ami,
le réalisateur Sabaah Folayan,
avons fait cela dans notre documentaire
« Des rues qui appartiennent à qui ? »
Je suis devenu un porte-parole
de tout ce courage qui m'était donné.
Je crois que c'est notre travail en tant qu'artistes.
Nous devrions véhiculer le courage dans le travail que nous réalisons.
Nous sommes le mur séparant les gens normaux
et les gens utilisant leur pouvoir pour répandre la peur et la haine,
en particulier dans de tels moments.
Je vais vous demander,
vous tous les moteurs et agitateurs,
les maîtres à penser :
qu'allez-vous faire
avec les dons que vous avez
pour nous libérer de la peur qui nous contraint chaque jour ?
Car j'ai peur chaque jour.
Depuis aussi longtemps que je m'en souvienne.
Une fois que j'ai compris que la peur n'était pas là pour me paralyser,
elle était là pour me protéger,
et que j'ai compris comment utiliser cette peur,
j'ai trouvé mon pouvoir.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)